I retired on a Friday packed up two
small bags locked my beach house and
flew to South boo food chili when you
make a big change in your life and I
frankly I'm not the kind of person to
make very many of those in my life but I
made a whopper when I decided to retire
and come down here it was a giant leap
of faith the idea has always been that
we would try to buy up the land that's
found between two pre-existing Chilean
national reserves creates all the
infrastructure here buy all the land
that we could and then we would donate
all of this to the Chilean government if
they would also agree to change the
status of the two neighboring national
reserves into national park and roll it
all into one category a national park on
any of these projects the easiest thing
you do is by the way it requires your
signature to sign the check and after
that things get really complicated
really fast
people who are working on conservation
projects you have to sort of stick
together because if it was easy work to
do
there'd be a lot more people doing it